what's up this your favorite Hood hi
this princess sexy red come check me out
on a boulette Kev podcast
show special guests in here repping St
Louis we got sexy red yes big sexy in
the beauty in the hood hottest princess
what's up what's going on uh first of
all congratulations you've had a quite
the uh last few months with pound town
going absolutely crazy thank you it is
uh it is a moment it is for Real it is
it reminds me I don't even know what it
reminds me of it reminds me of like some
two live cruise ship back in the day or
like yeah I'm glad you compared it to
that yeah like it's a pretty crazy
record yeah people saying freak neek and
stuff yeah I'm like well hell though I
don't understand
um I don't know that's it yeah I don't
know uh for you uh give me kind of like
a little bit of your like uh backstory
like like how first of all how long
you've been rapping
um I've been rapping for like four years
now it's probably finna be for years
so kind of like right before the
pandemic started you yes yes yes yes yes
yes right before and then that's my
[__] stuck in the house not
just making some and you were making
songs
um what what like how'd you grow up what
were you doing before music before music
I was doing her I used to be just
selling [__] like when I was young I was
a little slide sell some candy anything
I could sell but the last thing I was
doing before I became famous or whatever
was I was a hair stylist so you were
selling people's hair around St Louis no
I was doing everybody hair like
everybody here I was the hood hottest
hair stylist okay so everybody would
come to you get their [__] right
everybody knew I was like for real like
I was the one that did the hair the
right way right now my friends be
calling me like man I wish you still do
her don't nobody do her like you like
all my old clients they still wish I did
her I was like nope so how do you get
your hair stylist if you're a hair
stylist you gotta like have a real you
do your own [__] yeah I do my own oh
that's fair but but sometimes when I
have to get my hair done and I just
don't got time and they like sexy you
can't do your hair you can't do
everything we gotta get some idea then
I'll just be like all right find me
somebody you know you have a ton of
tattoos yeah uh you you have your whole
situation situated over there too yeah
how painful was that uh it didn't even
hurt like I I used to like pain when I
was young I got them a lot of these when
I was young okay what was the most
painful tattoo you have my chest or my
neck the neck
at the butt hurt too because it's like
it make you clench your ass like right
like you it's like you're getting
stabbed in the butt oh when I say that
hurt the whole time I was just clenching
my ass she's like oh and this is new the
sexy on the yeah I just got the on the
um where was we we was in Memphis a
little Memphis Trail you say you know
what let me get another face tap I love
it I love face tattoos
um yeah you've kind of like uh you don't
look like you got nothing for real I do
you do I got well I got my wife's name
right here okay that's cute my friend
just got her baby daddy name on her
finger and then I I got I got stuff
under my shirt oh you do I got my back
done
yeah I got to see your back cause I love
back testing do you yes I want my big
coat my hope it hurts I know the back
hurts for sure I'm a numbing
um yeah they're kind of like I feel like
uh you're kind of you know holding the
flag for like sexual freedom and Hip-Hop
right now you know what I'm saying like
they're saying yeah like I feel like
there's not a lot of like you know we
haven't seen a lot of artists who could
kind of like Embrace their sexuality as
such a big way like you have and what do
you mean by that like embrace my
sexuality I'm just saying like I think I
saw you on Instagram like running
through the adult bookstore you know
what I'm saying like I forget what city
you're in
you was in like the porno store no when
I was buying some stuff and I seen the
fan I forget what it was I think that's
what it was but I was like check her out
tap it in with the adult bookstore yeah
I'm going to the point of convention
this year are you excited yeah I ain't
booking or nothing like I ain't get
booked and I'm just saying like if
whatever convention they have in
whatever City I'm just gonna stop by
because I like [__] like that you gotta
get booked at the avns in Vegas what
it's called what that it may stand for
though ABN is the adult video Network
Awards it's like the Grammys of the of
the porn industry somebody just was
telling me about that I wanna they have
rappers perform every year they need to
talk to me they need to type in tap in I
want to come what's the go-to category
for you in terms of porn
um of course ebony but I like and I'm
like
ebony yeah ebony yeah of course ebony
yeah are you like a avid watcher of
exotic Cinema what they mean pornography
like do I like to watch it like you hop
on the Hub PornHub yeah yeah of course
yeah yeah I got a little private private
town I go to sometimes you always go
private tab yeah so your internet
history ain't all [__] up no yeah that
is embarrassing when you forget to go
private Tab and then someone hops on
your phone or they'll be like oh you
forget that it's on the screen yeah you
click on the on the uh the little
browser it pop up like I gotta have it
on my laptop where I was about to start
DJing a gig and I like I like set my
[__] you lie on a laptop I open my
screen and I'm like oh [__] in the
middle of the club don't be so embraced
you'd be like did anybody see that on
the side just naked just nakedness yeah
it's bad
um yo talk about so you're embarrassing
you did the [__] Me Out remix with uh my
boy Emily Choppa which uh that song just
went gold shout out to Anna Lee he type
yeah super nice guy whose idea was it to
do the the leash thing me that was your
idea yes
because you got a little Flack for that
I know that's wrong y'all I ain't been
wrong for that he didn't do nothing
wrong like they saw like I don't I
understand but he really didn't do
nothing wrong he just was doing what I
told him
that was all you were like look I got
this idea you're gonna walk me no it
wasn't even like that no it wasn't even
like that we just turned where I'm from
we turns up baby we getting on the
ground twerking we getting on our knees
we doing all that we doing splits flips
all day we going crazy so I was we was
already doing all that we was on our
knees it's working then I just said pull
my hair yeah see pull my hair we gonna
twerk and walk I like it
um people get their hair pulled all the
time so I don't understand like what was
I don't that's why I didn't understand
there's an art to pull in here though
what you mean well also
listen as somebody who's been with black
women in my life you're not supposed to
pull the hair yeah we were saying that
too because at first Suki was like nah
[__] nah we just gotta hurt you can't
pull a black woman no you can't and we
just got our hair done and I'm like
don't pull it too hard that's why he
just had it all like just yeah because
he had to go left he had it Loose
because I'm like hold on [__] man I
just got all right don't put my wig off
you doing a little too much doing a
little too much yeah yeah for people who
don't know don't pull a black woman's
hair she has to give you permission
don't yes I have to tell them yeah for
sure he was like [__] we just gotta
hurt and I'm like [__] I'm like been I
don't rip this wig off
um tell me more because look when I was
growing up as a kid the only thing I
knew about St Louis was uh the Country
Grammar video with Nelly and there was a
that [__] look lit as [__] it was I went
to St Louis one time and it was it was
dope I had a fun time yeah it felt kind
of like like old yeah that's what baby
saying everybody say like it's like oh
like that's why I don't know they say I
dress old back in the day and stuff yeah
what's St Louis like because I think
right now obviously you're the biggest
representation of St Louis and Hip-Hop
yes it's like it is oh it's like
old-fashioned it's like we we big daddy
like we not we see the new clothes but
we don't get to see that [__] like our
Mars went got all that kind of the Gucci
and Louis we haven't got [__] like that
we got it but it's gonna be a store that
got like the sale it's some little Gucci
[__] in here you know what I'm saying we
don't got to be there's not a Gucci
store in St Louis really hell no it's
not nothing like that like we don't we
it's like we get our [__] last we really
beg daddy years like I go to the new
stores I see all the stuff they go I'm
like we don't got we don't dress like
this on her
but they be saying I just like there
with my little track suits and stuff you
know like I don't know you have to see
my little office everywhere and they'd
be saying I just like the little 2000
but that's how that's how it is out
there and we watch old movies
oh Friday okay like [__] like they're
like uh Menace to Society boys in the
hood we watch oh [__] like they're like
that's that's what come on our TVs
that's what we we gonna say what movie
y'all want to watch and we're gonna name
some [__] like that type [__] so you
guys aren't watching new movies am I for
real but if you do you're gonna go to
the movies to see it or you know like
you just ain't gonna see it what about
TV shows what TV shows are you watching
they be watching Power and stuff like
they're like [__] I don't really watch
TV I'll be on YouTube but if I do watch
TV I watch weird [__] like
um I like this show love at the Lock Up
um I like to watch Judge Mathis Judge
Mathis I like Judge Judy couples course
you like all the [__] that you would
watch when you ditch school yeah just
like like that's the kind of [__] my
aunties used to watch when we was little
and we had to stay watch stay at the
house while we waiting on our peoples to
come get us so yeah rest in peace to
Jerry Springer yes Jerry Springer Maury
Morris audience a legend I like Steve
Wilkos
I like all these kind of shoes Suki
performed on Jerry Springer back in the
day yes he did I saw that I said I had
no idea I didn't even know they were
having people perform on Jerry before he
passed away that [__] crazy you didn't
know that I did not know it's a whole
bunch of people that perform Jenny Jones
back in the day he said people perform
you remember Jenny Jones never heard of
it Wiki Lake Ricky Lake I heard of it
but I never seen it yeah I heard people
say Ricky Lake but I don't know what
that is yeah Ricky lake is like she was
like I want to say she was before Jerry
Springer but that ain't for real yeah
when you were growing up were you like a
fan of the saint lunatics and when Nelly
was doing it today everybody was they
was what was popping in the city yeah
you know we're not used to famous people
it was like Changi Jaquan yeah who else
I mean
um am I missing anybody I don't miss
anybody is you missing some people is
the jibs Chain Hang Low guy from St
Louis yeah yeah it's a lot of people
from St Louis that you would have to sit
back and be like oh there he is from St
Louis like I forgot if they don't really
be doing nothing no more you know right
well he does country yeah
I think he's back with Ashanti oh for
real which is a good look for him
great look for him
she's aged gracefully yes I feel like
she's again she's looking younger yeah
she got some she got some wild G she got
them Pharrell jeans you know okay I saw
it was like for real still look this
[__] sign from what I was with
Pharrell looks the exact same from when
I was little a lot of a lot of the
artists be looking at something from
when I was little I'd be like like sure
who you're not sure well sure I think
her name is sure but I say sure
oh [__] share yeah you know what [__]
well she's first of all next I see a
vampire well you know my age listen
when it comes to Pharrell
I will say this black people and Asian
people age the best
white people if you're share and you're
an old white lady that's all money
no she it's all plastic surgery that
lady's got so much [__] and just things
on her face God bless her she just did
you see she was dating like a young dude
uh like a like she was dating like a 35
year old guy
for ocean the bay yeah he was like he
used to work with Tyga like a r and they
thought he was like trying to take a
frog okay period I'm not as right they
were supposed to get married and they uh
they broke it off because she I think
she felt like she might have been
getting uh play play a little yeah damn
see it'd be like them young I saw you
your new record uh the female Gucci Mane
is fire thanks appreciate it what makes
you the female Gucci Mane this is what
they be seeing I don't know ask the
people let's ask the people because I
don't know that's what they say for I
ain't just calling myself that they be
saying that they said it so much I I
just made a song about it I'm not
calling myself the female Gucci but if
that's what y'all want to say
because it just went like I heard the
beat and I'm like okay female Gucci man
I just kept rapping do you know if
Gucci's heard this record I don't know
did you like send it off to him like Hey
man I did [__] out no I'm so my fans
didn't text him or something with him he
probably didn't heard it yeah
yeah are you the type of person if
you're on the road because you've been
getting bags running around performing
everywhere do you hit the local strip
club to support the local talent no I'm
not gonna lie I don't like strip clubs
really I don't what's wrong with that I
don't like clubs period I ain't even
gonna say I don't like strip clubs I
don't like clothes she's like unless
they're paying me yes unless they plan
me but even when they do pay me I'm
gonna be honest I don't like the clue if
it's fun and y'all turn me up then it's
different but honestly I don't like the
club I don't like when strippers be
trying to dance on me and do all that
unless I ask you don't just come over to
me
yeah see the money yeah come don't come
sit on me I don't want none of that so
I'm letting y'all know now you would
like to keep your money no not even that
just don't even come like if I approach
you and I'll tell you like yeah that's
different but for you to just if you saw
in love that's cool hey bye but I don't
be I don't know I don't be with all that
cause I'm I don't like strip clubs I
don't like clubs period I'm not I'm not
friendly but I [__] with whoever [__]
with me you know so you rather you're
like would you consider yourself a
homebody yeah I am you'll be at the crib
yeah I do chilling yeah I do I'll be
chilling I used to be outside [__] I
still get outside but that's when I want
to right it ain't just like because I do
it I get paid to do it all the time so
it's not bad for me no I'm saying I saw
you in uh you were in Miami was it for
spring break
that looked pretty wild yeah that was
fun how was that look you got you guys
look like it was like vintage spring
break action popping that's why they
were saying freak meat it was fun as
[__] yeah it was fun I had them hoes
turn we was outside
I mean you were literally outside yeah I
want to say you were running around with
no shirt on am I tripping no I had a
bikini top okay maybe I'm tripping then
I think I feel like I saw one of your
Vlogs and I was like is she got no shirt
no well shout out to you I would but no
that wouldn't mean yo what up it's
bootleg cab we gotta stop the interview
to tell you about our folks at my bookie
that's right so many ways you can gamble
with my bookie right now man of course
you got NBA playoffs Western Conference
Finals Eastern Conference Finals they're
set I love Celtics versus Lakers in the
finals all right you can sign up at
mybookie.ag right now using that promo
code bootleg and get a very generous
first deposit bonus that's right and
they just got the craziest like revamp
of the online casino it's like a Las
Vegas experience if you play cards
Blackjack roulette uh you shoot dice
whatever it is they have like live
dealers handling it for you wherever
you're at you could be at the airport
and be playing [__] roulette on your
phone it's amazing mybookie.ag sign up
with that promo code bootleg right now
you can bet on Sports you could do slots
you could do blackjack craps whatever
you're into mybookie.ag promo code
bootleg for that first deposit bonus and
it is a generous one also got to give a
shout out to our family at King Palms
shout out to King Palm man if you only
know about King Palms you're our new
sponsor on the bootleg cat podcast and
they got such a great product the best
thing about King Palms is it's all
organic man no tobacco in these wraps
they're straight Leafs and the best
thing uh about them is they got this
product
their flavor terpene tips all right you
stuff them with your with your product
do we got one here oh we do got one here
all right we got one right here we got
one right here all right
you stuff this with your uh premium
cannabis from Hardy in Las Vegas
all right you smoke up pinch that tip
you're gonna get a burst of flavor yeah
this is the energy drink flavor we got
Peach pineapple we got watermelon wave
also don't forget the goddamn
blue grapes you know what I mean and
also this is a tobacco-free wrap it's
totally organic it's literally a leaf
let me show you what I mean
that is just a big ass Leaf guys all
right so what you could do is go to
kingpom.com weeds flying everywhere
kingpom.com promo code bootleg and you
can get 50 off of whatever you order at
kingpom.com and don't forget to check
them out because they're everywhere your
local smoke shop your local liquor store
7-Eleven smoke the King Palm all right
it's organic it ain't like all that
other [__] y'all be [__] stuffing
in your lungs man all right shout out to
kickpong kingpom.com promo code bootleg
right now and it's actually promo code
bootleg Kev promo code bootleg Kev not
bootleg bootleg cab kingpom.com half off
everything let's get back to the
interview uh are you working on an album
right now uh I'm working I got a lot of
music I'll just be working on songs but
it's so many good ones we trying to see
which ones to put on a little mixtape or
whatever I'll drop like a mixtape
because you've been putting singles out
yeah I don't want to drop no album
I know they want me to drop it off but I
just want to start small and see what
they do and then go crazy
did you have any idea when you wrapped
the coochie pink the booty hole Brown
that uh that would be such a viral no
because I hear that [__] all the [__]
time
it's crazy
you crack me up now
because it's just like y'all really fine
I laugh like y'all really find this
funny and it just makes me sure it
didn't make me laugh at first because
I'm like I'm being dead serious yeah uh
like I have my boy a propane send me
your [__] maybe like two months ago and
he was like uh
yo this shit's about to be huge really
everybody was saying it and then I heard
the the song and I was like this is
different this [__] is raw how was
different it was just very it's a very
transparent song thank you it's a very
transparent oh we missed our Cloud we
got to get it right there it is wow boom
yeah and then like uh the the line about
trying to find your kid a new Pappy just
had me die that was money people
everybody was laughing but I did
yeah I'm just talking and then they be
laughing I'll be like what I say what I
say who's been like one of the
celebrities that you saw like singing
along your [__] or posting your [__]
that you were like whoa that's crazy
like my song's that big like they didn't
reach this person I ain't gonna lie I
probably don't even remember now because
it's just it's so many so many of them
now you you see it I'd be surprised
about all of them for real cause I ain't
know the song was gonna even I'm like
yeah I really like this song because it
correct me from the cardi B say
something about it yeah everybody
business when I say everybody everybody
named mama that's why I'm shocked so
every time it's a new person I'll just
be like hey it's crazy it's just going
all around I feel like a pound town
remix with cardi B would be Monumental
they were saying that it's a lot of
people that was like it's a lot of
people I want to put on there I don't
know how long what do you want to put on
it I don't know I don't want to name
drop nobody well you know Anna Lee Chapa
did two like officially two remixes of
slept me out I know I do like three or
four I might do do something like that
or just put her body on the same song
you could and just have it you know
Trina with Trina would be dope a lot of
people it's a lot of people I could
think of who are some of the female
rappers you grew up listening to that
you kind of can say you're influenced by
um I was listening to Trina everybody
used to listen to Nikki everybody used
to sleep
um who else what other females I ain't
got a lot I like music so it's nobody
specific like but Trina definitely was
on my training Nikki was definitely on
my uh MP3 player downloaded and my mom
used to heard that she used to be like
you just took us back the MP3 player
yeah that's why I'm saying like when I
used to listen to music and [__] we used
to download [__] like that I used to
download Boosie Webbie all the Boosie
and Webbie music have you met busier yet
yeah I met him okay because I always
tell people when you meet him he's he
doesn't disappoint
because you know you'll see sometimes
you meet famous people that you like
yeah he cool and they'll be like oh this
guy was a dick or he's not like how
usually yes you mean boozy and he's like
exactly who you think he is yeah Boosie
cool I mean him he was like um when I
met him I was with Suki and she brought
me to his house he was having a little
party and him and sukiku so I was with
her and [__] and then he was like don't
never take your glasses off keep on them
[__] glasses
it's a nice I feel like yeah I feel like
the glass is like a dope like I like the
glasses yeah I like my little glasses
you need them to see yes I can't see I'm
blind for real damn yes I was mad when I
lost him I lost my glasses before and I
could not see like but I feel like you
could tell I can't see because you could
tell when people need glasses you see it
like I don't think do you need glasses
no my my mom I grew up with my mom and
my grandma were like blind so so you
don't need them no I don't I'm fine
that's why I'm saying like your eyes
wide open I was gonna say you don't look
like you need them okay I don't but I
didn't see people when they are you know
how somebody eyes be squinting yeah like
they trying to see you can tell like
they need them yeah like that's how my
eyes are my eyes be a little love when I
don't got my glasses do you feel like uh
when when your first record that wreck
really takes off nationally is pound
town you got to kind of follow up like
more kind of like like I'ma just keep
doing what I do because if you try to
put too much pressure on me and hurting
you and try to be like oh he gotta
you're gonna stress yourself out so I'ma
just keep doing what I do drop that [__]
whatever I like about the female Gucci
Mane record because I feel like it's
like a different type of record and it's
just hard yeah it is different from
pound town I just be dropping my songs
how I feel like dropping them like I
don't be knowing which one I'm gonna
take off it's just half of the fans
feeling and then but since Pound Town
out now my music being in a lot of all
the other songs have been getting loved
yeah even my new ones like everybody
been seeing what's going on and they
like oh she she tight she had different
look categories yo how crazy is St Louis
because every time like a most dangerous
cities in America list like comes out I
feel like St Louis is always in the top
like two or three it'd be number one
sometimes yeah it's number one sometimes
it is number two it's dangerous because
people who's out there you can everybody
can carry a gun you can be it's open
carry yeah and you can be a kid and have
a gun [__] gonna be selling
guns to kids they do sell guns kids
they'd be like kids with guns like it
was just some stuff that happened a
minute ago the girl and her friend or
her cousin they was in the bathroom
playing with a gun and she accidentally
shot him in the back of the head because
they was playing with the gun and then
she killed herself on a live video
cheese it was sad but I'm just like see
this I only want my son growing up in St
Louis honestly how about your kid how
old is he he too two years old yes yes
how's it is it hard to like you know
juggle being a superstar rapper and
being a mom of a two-year-old yes it is
hard because I'll be missing him
sometimes I gotta be away from him for a
couple days at a time
and then I'll see him a week week at a
time two weeks at a time who's helping
with the kid grandma Yeah the grannies
and my baby daddy used to help before he
got locked up baby I have help baby
daddy's incarcerated yeah or you guys uh
cordial yeah we cool as [__] that's my
[__] like we still cool is he like uh
like are you waiting for him to get out
yeah yeah when he get out like you're
talking about for us to be together yeah
no when he like before he got locked up
he was a hoe and was talking to other
people but he still would come spend the
night at my house we still school right
we weren't [__] enough we just was
real cool you guys are friends yeah me
and my baby daddy friends before
anything and she like have any idea how
big you are right now he know now and
he's shocked because he see he said
people in jail be singing all my songs
and you know it's people in jail with
phones yo what imagine a bunch of men in
jail singing pound town they do big paws
they do though he said they mean yo
imagine a bunch of grown-ass men talking
about pound town I don't want to hear
that in jail and they play it on the
radio though so he gonna hear it on the
road it'd be on the radio in jail he
don't that would be the soundtrack I
don't want in a Men's prison he said
it's the gay boy in there he said the
boy walking around pound town just left
pound town and he's probably actually
just left pound town in the shower he
said he acting like he said he rapping
like me he said he's trying to change
his voice to sound like how I talk wow
he's so funny that's so funny and then
when I was on the phone with him we was
on the phone he was already telling me
about it I started hearing him in the
background I said is that him and he
started laughing he was like yeah he
just be in himself just hauling my
lyrics that's so funny is that a
cellmate no hey [__] no I don't know you
know people no he said he'd be hollering
from all the way down the hall pound
town so like that's that's got to be
pretty dope to be a baby daddy yeah yeah
he said no he don't he don't they know
he my baby daddy now because they
watching all my old videos and they see
who he is he said they coming up to him
in jail saying is you is you sexy red
baby like and he but he not oh yeah this
is my baby mother he don't be he not
like that does your son is he like in
the like you know my kids are young and
they're on YouTube a lot nah my son he
he don't know about YouTube he too well
he be on YouTube he's badass he'd be
watching kids [__] dog yeah like the
kids like some of those kids channels
are crazy yeah Ryan's toy review there's
this Asian kid who just opens toys and
like makes millions and millions of
dollars what kind of toys like just
anything they're literally bad toys no
good toys uh like you know like uh I
think he'd be having sex
no it's the same it's a little kid and
he just reviews toys with his dad
they're so cute and the [__] oh man
Chucky can do something like that oh you
would go crazy
if you start a YouTube channel doing
that or a tick tock you're [__] paid
oh you think so just open the toys yeah
cause he get toys all day just open them
and review them and people gonna be
wanting to see him soon and you just be
yourself for real yes cause when we be
opening them my son be excited he'd be
like
I'd be like yeah you got your toys I'm
like listen how we finna put this [__]
together like how the [__] are we
feeling oh that's going viral we'll be
sitting there putting the [__] together
millions of views and he'd be so excited
he'd be excited like yeah oh you're
going you're going up with that all
right Cinema yeah yeah yeah shout out to
your kid yeah you're you're yeah hey lud
is she he's so small he loves new [__]
every time you come home you bring him
some new [__] like I've been gone two or
three days yeah I got you you know I do
of course I think about them all day so
while I'm out if I'm getting myself some
clothes I'll be like hold on they got
kids in here any store I got so if they
got kids [__] I'm shopping for myself
are you gonna do anything for yourself
for Mother's Day or for your mom I'm not
really celebrating it for real I don't
know like do you like because mom's been
helping out you you know maybe take more
of a spa day or something first I'm
gonna turn her up yeah of course yeah
that's a good idea too I should have
planned us a spa day but I gotta see if
we're gonna keep the [__] kids you
say you don't want your kid growing up
in St Louis you plan on leaving
um yeah I do I ain't gonna because at
first I was gonna stay but they be
hating too bad and I ain't know it was
gonna get like how it is because I'm
thinking I could get real big but this
one I wasn't as big as I am now I think
I get real big and stay where I'm at
right but I see I came
I wasn't gonna be able to do that
because now I'm where I you know I'm
saying I'm getting bigger and I see
what's going on yeah they say like you
get more hate from where you're from
than anywhere else you do I do when I
say they be hating so bad I mean it's
crazy I'd be like damn like I don't know
many people who stayed like I mean
obviously Atlanta you'd want to stay in
Atlanta if you're from Atlanta because
it's Atlanta but I feel like everybody
else like from like random cities like I
don't know anybody from Baton Rouge the
state of Baton Rouge yeah type [__] I
give what you're saying Boosie Atlanta
Fredo bangs in Miami like yeah yeah I
get what you're saying yeah
[__] always yeah move out
because it's where you from they be
heading the most because they be feeling
like how come it ain't them how come her
right so that is how it goes yes so
they're not gonna support us because you
only make pound town okay but I've been
doing this [__] that's why they mad
cause they like she steady this [__]
steady done going viral doing this this
I don't know I just always go borrow
I'll just be doing some
gotta stop the interview real quick to
tell you about our family at Blue chew
baby that's right it's getting hot
outside you know what that means fellas
you're about to go get that dick wet you
know what I'm saying it might as well be
really hard it might as well be as hard
as it could possibly be and with
Bluetooth you will achieve such hardness
all right it's seriously amazing uh and
the best part about Bluetooth is you can
find out if it works don't just take my
word for it they're going to give you a
month's supply for free go to
bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg get a month supply for free
bluetooth.com promo code bootleg now
it's the same active ingredient as
Viagra and Cialis minus the awkward
doctor appointment you do not have to go
see some old dude and tell them about
your erectile dysfunction issues in
person because that's a [__] awkward
conversation bruh all you got to do is
go to bluetooth.com right now use the
promo code bootleg they're going to get
you hooked up with a month of supply for
free you just got to pay five dollars in
shipping no awkward doctor's
appointments same active ingredient as
Viagra and Cialis plus they got the
Bluetooth mint it's a chewable it's
great tastes like mint it's also the
same active ingredient as Levitra so
summertime's coming fellas you don't
want to underperform make sure your dick
is rocked up baby all right go to
bluetooth.com use the promo code bootleg
hey man it works what do you want from
me it [__] works everyone should have
a little Bluetooth in case of an
emergency
you might have an emergency you need to
pop a Bluetooth to it it's a chewable
you know what I mean anyway also got a
shout out to our family at Odd Socks
don't forget go to oddstocksofficial.com
promo code bootleg save 20 off man they
got the underwear that they just dropped
uh last year that's amazing so not only
do you get the most comfortable socks in
the world but you can also get the most
comfortable withdrawals in the world all
the crazy licenses they gotta have baked
socks they just announced their Hasbro
collection which is crazy because that
means you're going to get Monopoly socks
Transformer socks Power Ranger socks so
much [__] going with Odd Socks plus they
got The Odd Socks Basics my favorite
this is why I wear every day I wear the
basics because they're the most
comfortable socks I've ever put on my
[__] feet so experience the most
comfortable socks in the world with me
oddsoxofficial.com promo code bootleg
save 20 off shout out to Odd Socks let's
get back to the interview have any of
the St Louis OG rappers reached out like
have you got a DM from Chingy no no no
but
um
who didn't wrote me before somebody
didn't wrote me before jibs wrote me
before jibs a couple people didn't rob
me but not number Louis the man Louis
Vuitton man hey Sammy yeah Louis Vuitton
man it's called do your own dance do you
know who smino is
um he's dope he's from St Louis I mean I
heard of him he'd be working with like J
Cole and like uh he's fired he'd be
singing or something he sings and raps
he's fire you just tap in that would be
kind of a random collapse because Mina
was popping he just headlined a big tour
like he's he's I heard about him but
where I'm from
um like what we don't listen to stuff
like that okay give me an uh an idea of
what because for people who don't know
when you go to St Louis it's borders
Illinois and there's East St Louis which
is like by all accounts supposed to be
kind of like a a pretty you know
serious place to go yeah East St Louis
uh um so you go down over there too so
what is there like a rivalry between
like St Louis Missouri and East St Louis
yes they don't like people from the East
side interesting it's like the East Side
beefing with us I don't know Well we'd
be with them they'd just be sneak
dissing like they even be trying to act
like they disclaiming me and say I'm
from Nissan that's how St Louis they try
to be funny and say [__] like that
they'd be like ah nah she from the east
side or something like that's when you
just like oh [__] [__] you okay do you
grow up ever watching the St Louis
Cardinals you have the logo on your face
I don't know if you like did you grow up
watching Mark McGuire or Albert Pujols
or anybody I just really love my CD
though right even though they some
[__] haters and they hate me I love
what I am I love who I am like if I
ain't come from St Louis and I came from
somewhere else I probably wouldn't be me
you know what I'm saying for sure
because I'm a product of my environment
and I'm happy with who I am so okay so
what's coming next for you uh more music
yes more music [__] with me go [__] with
my old music I've been there I been hard
uh pound town remix have you gotten any
verses for it yet no I mean you know yes
I think JT was actually JT was saying
she was gonna put a little verse on oh
JT might be on the remix No it'd be it's
a lot of people that say lately they
want to put some verses on that and
people been remixing it by itself like
just taking a song and making their own
little version of pound town I've been
seeing a lot of reasons so pound town
remix with JT on the way no I don't know
who gonna be on there everybody just
saying like they gonna put verses on
there I might do like a lot of a lot of
them put together type [__] because
there's so many that I want on there
what dude I can't just pick one could
you put a dude on the pound town remix
and who would it that's who I want I
want some [__] on there for sure for
so like because I'm already talking
about pound town I need a [__] to come
on there and say pal you know do his
part and say what he want to say I said
Brown what if you put Saucy Santana on
the pound town remix he did his own
remix too I didn't see that you did I
didn't know he's a great guy though I
want to show you can I show you yeah
please I love sausages he's one of my
favorite interviews I've ever done okay
period I'm glad he's such a nice guy
that's what's up let me go to him I just
feel like the pound town with the gay
rapper would be fired right period the
dude's in jail would love it
I don't know about all dudes well the
guy you were talking about yeah oh God
but I love to get community gay
community love me have they embraced you
hell yeah they [__] with me they they've
been loving me I feel like you know if
you have the gay audience in hip-hop
you're [__] lit like Trina like gay
people love Trina they love Little Kim
they love Nikki I got all the audiences
this thing I got the emo [__] emo
[__] what is an emo [__] a emo [__]
is like a um like a rock star [__] I
like [__] like that
[__] look Gothic the weirdos I like
that kind of [__] too cause I'm like a
little Hood emo [__] like you know I
got the little Earths I like in anime
and whatever however you said I think
it's anime but I'll be seeing people say
anime it's definitely anime it's anime I
like Annie which and a name do you like
yeah which a name yeah
um I like I just like to just like I
like the way you can get a cosplay
costume like I like to get the costume
like I didn't just look like Spider-Man
before I be just wearing characters I
could wear I had some bloody ears you
know like I just like she like to dress
up and like the costumes have you ever
been to like uh Comic-Con but I want to
go I would turn the [__] up in her I
want to go she's never watched like
Dragon Ball Z or yeah I used to watch
Pokemon Pokemon's great I love Pokemon
everybody dude I think everybody did you
just watch Pokemon everybody legendary
anime yeah period oh God I used to watch
a lot of that [__] back in the day when
I was little
I'll watch it today I like cartoons do
you like rock music you say you're kind
of like a god do you like some rocks I
like all kinds of stuff I'm weird like I
like stuff people think I wouldn't even
like like people like oh you you liked
it but I got the emo beaches I got the
[__] the hood [__] I got the beaches
I like [__] be strikeless to my muse
you know what I'm saying so I got the
[__] the [__] the gay people
everybody all the categories Pokemon you
got the Coalition even the white people
don't [__] with me the whites the whites
the whites the whites yeah the whites
[__] with me they're quite shout out to
the whites those are the quotes I [__]
with the quipes I love the Caucasians I
love y'all I do I love Caucasians they
funny thank you
anyway well look I can't wait to hear it
thank you the new music sounds like no
look oh this is this the sauce okay let
me see
look how many like
[Music]
Santa Claus the Trap yeah you know what
I'm talking about rap you know I'm
pregnant
not too late
he said I'm pregnant I'm pregnant oh
that's great hey did you see this clip
that went viral recently of uh
I think her name's ebony she was she she
was she got asked if she would ever date
a bus driver and she said she would only
date a bus driver if he owned the bus
and there's like all this like
uh I wouldn't say outrage but people
were kind of mad that she was
essentially saying that you know she
wouldn't date anybody unless they had
something like real going on that's her
preference that can't be mad yeah you
know would you would you date a bus
driver
um
or would you date someone who made less
money than you I
have no I'm just getting some money
right I'm still regular to me they say
I'm famous but I feel like I'm really
like I'll be talking to people that
don't they got less money to me like
it's not it's you you know I ain't got
you no money you're gonna keep doing you
and I'll keep doing me you know what I'm
saying that's all that is we can be cool
and I'm gonna spend the same I'm gonna
be on the same type of time you own like
you can only spend 700. I'm gonna spend
700 I'm gonna be on your type of time
like I'm
yeah when's the new music coming
um any more songs dropping song yes I
got a song ski
that's the car that's the bird called
you heard skiing let me pull up [__]
yeah I got that finna drop female Gucci
Mane y'all [__] go just go [__] with my
[__] she got catalog go running I got a
catalog I got all kinds of [__] finish
off hellcats srts [__] come pull up on
me it's a lot of [__] sexy red ladies
and gentlemen thank you for pulling up
thanks for having me of course high five
boom boom hey we gotta wrap up an
interview brought to you by hardean Las
Vegas appreciate y'all watching hey
don't forget when you go to Vegas you
got to go to Hardee man it's the
craziest dispensary you'll ever walk
into it smells like [__] heaven in
there all right get in that Uber when
you hit Sin City tell him take me to
hardine they're gonna take you you're
gonna get a wild selection of the just
top top of the line cannabis the best
selection you'll go uh uh be able to see
in the U.S Plus on top of that they got
the crazy gear they got the clothes they
got the bikinis they got a wonderful
selection of Bud tenders that are very
good at their job man they'll take care
of you tell them that bootleg have sent
you the bud tenders are Harding don't
know what that means they're gonna get
you hooked up right all right go follow
them online Harding underscore Las Vegas
or just go check out their website too
man hardinglasvegas.com and when you're
in Vegas pull up to Jardin or you're
playing yourself for real